and then one day I went to Mr Olympia
okay and I hung out with all these guys
but put the picture with me and Dory and
Yates top left look this is him and I
when he this is at his Peak when he was
killing everybody and at the bottom 20
some years later we meet each other it's
an interesting picture right so with him
right there yeah that is Venice that's
Venice had a tattoo parlor so that's
Advent of speech yeah so we meet the
second time around but I went to Mr
Olympia Vegas never forget because a lot
of [ __ ] happened when I was on Mr
Olympia good bad and ugly all combine it
to my life change at this Mr Olympia
event so and I hung out with all these
guys these are guys that would compete
sixth place fifth place fourth place
their party and heart these guys are
partying like freaking rock stars it was
insane the [ __ ] they were doing stays
between us and them but they were
partying like freaking rock stars
and I said listen guys I want to go into
this space what do I need to do what do
you need to do [ __ ] you really want to
go through let's go through it Winnie
the sauce
all of this stuff that they went through
and I'm like yeah I'm not gonna do it
and I stepped away and the average
bodybuilder was five Mr Olympia's five
ten is a good height five eight five ten
six two and a half Arnold that's in the
70s you ain't gonna do it today today
you have to be five eight five nine five
ten and I stepped away what I liked
about it was the fact that they managed
expectations with me up front and I made
a decision as a kid when I say kid I'm
21 I'm a grown man but you know it's a
kid compared to these men that are 32 34
35 years old you're also 6'4 Pat despite
what the internet says I totally get it
I am 6'4 but what I'm trying to say is
that made me want to say yeah you look
like that because you're using that I
don't have to worry about anything I'm
stepping away that's probably the
biggest challenge I have with this here
is
the fact that it makes a guy sit there
and say
dude maybe I freaking suck so it
actually when you're talking about the
anxiety the four thousand to eighty
thousand people committing suicide the
other day I sent a message a guy texts
me back saying Pat I'm about to kill
myself I'm already talking about to call
this guy like what you're saying is true
it's very very true but I think the
cause of it Brian is
um
this guy was talking to a hotel like so
how's your marriage oh my wife and I
never argue I'm like [ __ ] I'm never
getting married because all I saw is my
mom and dad arguing yeah versus I talk
to you on a cow's marriage what are you
talking about 30 minutes ago we just
fought and it was a pretty bad fight
and marriage is hard and it sucks at
times matter of fact eighty percent time
it sucks because you're dealing with
kids in-laws arguments insecurities your
fears your days finances that are it's
freaking sucks 80 time then I say I'm
willing to get married versus oh we have
a perfect measure I don't want to get
married if you're because I'm never
going to be able to compete with
perfection so I think I think the reason
why people are having so many suicide
and anxiety and panic because they see
so much Perfection with a Kim Kardashian
they see so much Perfection with all
these other people and they say
that I can never amount to this so the
story you're telling now and just
opening up to saying you know I I messed
up royally here's where I'm at uh
believe it or not I'm sure you feel like
you got a thousand pounds off your back
that you're like dude [ __ ] this is
awesome that I don't have to carry this
[ __ ] anymore but also same time I think
if I do maybe I'm alone in this year
maybe I'm just the only one that thinks
like this and fans don't but if I
typically I can understand how the fans
would relate to this I think that's
probably the biggest frustration with
this story because it makes them feel
like when they compare to you maybe
you're just a human specimen and I can
never be like you you know what I'm
saying yeah I think that's the biggest
pain that they're having yeah
you know I love what you said about your
dad
um that advice is incredible
um I love that
um you know as I was growing up my my
dad died before I have a memory of him I
have no memory of him
and uh I didn't have anybody to put
their arm around me you know to Mentor
me and this is not my excuse right but
um but but what I will say is uh I feel
like I've had the opportunity to Mentor
a lot of young men and I feel like when
you say you feel like some weight has
been lifted absolutely I do but for
about one [ __ ] minute because then on
the other shoulder it's like well
there's all this other weight you know
because now I'm going to face everything
that I'm dealing with right now and now
I feel a deeper sense of responsibility
and obligation you know to to say we
have to acknowledge that the world is
hurting at record rates and there's this
path forward and it's a simple solution
it doesn't cost anything I understand
the frustration it totally makes sense
um it to me it doesn't change the path
forward it's like we we still nobody's
talking about a lot of these things you
know it's like I want to forcefully talk
about a lot of these things and then I
want to be able to talk about well again
there's
modern day primitive culture tribes live
this way early ancestors live this way
you know a lot of people actually are
talking about it like Andrew huberman
Joe Rogan is actually even talking about
a lot of this stuff they're not calling
them the nine essential tenants but
they're all talking about sleep they're
all talking about eat they're all
talking about they're all talking about
these same things and so what I'm and
they're talking about it you know in
sort of like a disjointed way you know
so what I'm trying to do is talk about
it in a very well organized packaged way
here's what we can do so that we don't
live with depression so that we don't
have suicidal ideation yes we we have a
lot that to measure up to especially
when it's a false expectation but I
believe when you know your roles and
goals in life and I believe when you're
making progress with your roles and
goals in life and I believe that when
you because a lot of people are like
okay like it's this one thing it's this
one thing it's tough to measure up to
the Kim Kardashian it's tough to measure
up to the liver King well it's so
multifactorial you know do you know how
many times somebody's had extreme
anxiety and what they've actually had is
a nutrient deficiency and so many kids
that have been in and out of psychiatric
Wards all all they've done is start
eating liver I don't give a [ __ ] who's
so if you're not even buying a
supplement they start eating liver and
they've not been and back into a
psychiatric ward and their anxiety and
obsessive compulsive is gone you know
and once again it's not just how you eat
it's how you move it's getting
connection with the sun it's putting
down the damn phone it's the bond
ancestral tenant it's all nine of these
things so there's no doubt what you said
is true um setting an expectation that
that that's impossible to meet this is
unfair right but but it's so much deeper
than that which is why I'll say you know
it's all nine ancestral tenants once
again I I know this you know I gotta own
this and that's why on the other
shoulder I'm like [ __ ] you know there's
even more weight now now I have to
actually like do a much better job at
leading this charge
yeah I I I I understand I I just want to
make sure that uh you you you see the
pain the fan is going to get if they
think they can never be like these nine
tenants I I agree with every one of them
sleep eat move Shields connect cold Sun
fight Bond you saw what O'Malley said he
says it sucks that this is happening
because this is actually an effective
philosophy like what this is this is
solid you know it the the steroids being
not disclosed no I'm fully natural I'm
this I'm not this unfortunately taints
this a little bit right this has a lot
of credibility what you're saying here
is who's debating this there's a bunch
of people that are talking about this
but but I think it's it's just
understanding that
um the fan is sitting there saying I can
never be like this guy I was having a
conversation I get it I I I was that
from 10 11 12 13 14 15. I could never be
like anybody around me I could never
measure up to that so then you
understand the pain that they were this
is what I'm saying like I feel like I
let a whole generation down perfect so
with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks right if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks right
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red are black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people weren't in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future looks bad toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
[Music]